[Applauso]
Una cosa è certa tutti noi abbiamo un
innato e innegabile bisogno di dare un
senso alle cose
è ciò che ci spinge a cercare
conoscenza e comprensione ed è ciò che
ci rende umani Noi
afferriamo visivamente ciò che la luce
imprime sulla nostra retina niente di
più niente di meno o almeno così sembra
Stasera vi vorrei parlarvi alcune cose
che sappiamo sul processo della
percezione in special modo visiva dunque
si diceva che quello che si deposita
sulla nostra retina è quello che noi
prendiamo del mondo niente di più o
niente di meno e se magari invece
rendessimo delle cose che non ci sono
facciamo un piccolo esperimento vedete
il puntino sopra la e
Ecco adesso
ve lo ingrandisco un po' così si vede
meglio
Ecco Vi chiedo un po' di collaborazione
quindici secondi della vostra attenzione
tra un attimo Quel puntino entrerà nel
bel mezzo della e rimarrà lì fermo per
15 secondi vi chiedo di guardare Quel
puntino per 15 secondi evitando se
possibile di sbattere le palpebre Quindi
battetele adesso
e vediamo cosa succede
Ecco se continuate a guardare i puntino
rosso vedrete ancora la e in contrasto
in nero più sbattete gli occhi più la
cosa scompare per poi riapparire abbiamo
visto Dunque una e che non c'è e se
vediamo dei
fantasmi Allora ci chiediamo Che cos'è
Allora il mondo
il mondo che ci circonda è una
costruzione del nostro cervello perché
questo è l'effetto della persistenza
retinica noi vediamo sono ciò che siamo
in grado di percepire ma in realtà ci
sono altri reami della realtà che ci
rimangono completamente sconosciuti
perché non li possiamo vedere quindi
domandiamoci
cosa Vediamo come si fa a sapere che
quello che vedo è vero
quello che penso è reale Come possiamo
distinguere illusione e realtà
domande come queste presuppongono tutte
un fatto che però è evidente la
percezione non è solo una questione di
come vediamo il mondo o di come lo
interpretiamo ma è anche uno strumento
con il quale decidiamo di interagire con
il mondo
il movimento per esempio
l'impressione del movimento come mai è
chiaro non è una caratteristica della
sensazione quanto della percezione
Ovvero della elaborazione che noi
facciamo delle sensazioni e queste
sensazioni aggiungono materiale alla
lettura dell'evento a cui stiamo
assistendo nella loro completezza vi
faccio un esempio quando vediamo
qualcuno che cammina per strada non
vediamo solamente uno che cammina per
strada
siamo non solamente consapevoli del suo
movimento ma riusciamo anche a
comprendere la sua direzione la sua
velocità
questo perché la nostra mente ha
aggiunto alcuni elementi che possono
essere presenti o meno nella sensazione
stessa la nostra mente aggiunge
costantemente
elementi che possono essere o meno
presenti nelle sensazioni che riceviamo
dal corpo
sono
interpretazioni previsioni aspettative
che ci aiutano a comprendere come il
mondo fornendoci informazioni su quello
che è accaduto e dandoci delle
indicazioni su quello che forse accadrà
torniamo a noi alla luce
la luce attraversando cornea e
cristallino scolpisce per così dire la
nostra retina con una incisione i cui
segno persiste resiste per un certo
tempo maggiore è la potenza di questa
fonte di luce che stiamo guardando più
lungamente questa impressione permane la
e che avete visto prima funziona proprio
così Ma come è collegata Allora la
persistenza della visione con la
percezione del Movimento vi faccio
vedere una piccola
animazione in cui viene disegnato un
ragazzo che cammina nella vostra
direzione sono due fotogrammi al secondo
e però noterete
noterete
come pur vedendo gli scatti noi
percepiamo anche il movimento
abbiamo visto due immagini messe in
sequenza e ho montato il video in modo
tale che sembrasse che venisse in avanti
ma se ci pensate Avete visto proprio il
braccio che faceva il movimento mentre
in realtà non è così vi faccio un altro
esempio
i fotogrammi qua sono 12 al secondo
Beh quando vediamo un filmato a 12
fotogrammi al secondo cominciamo a
perdere la percezione del singolo
fotogramma e veniamo immersi per così
dire nel movimento e grazie a questa
persistenza che prende il via il
processo grazie alla quale possiamo
vedere un film al cinema o in TV nella
successione di fotogrammi Quando si
arriva addirittura a vederne 24 o più al
secondo noi abbiamo la illusione del
Movimento perfetto È solo un'illusione
perché in realtà quello che vediamo È
una serie ben precisa di immagini
statiche
solo che vengono proposte alla nostra
percezione a una velocità tale e ha una
numero tale che incontra la nostra
specializzazione per riuscire a
percepire il movimento
la persistenza della visione lascia
un'impronta quindi che è un incisione
questa incisione che dura pochi
millisecondi questa incisione viene
chiamata anche After image il nostro
cervello interpreta il mondo visivo in
modo continuo e sequenziale costruendo
un'esperienza ininterrotta a partire da
piccoli frammenti
un evento che ci sembra istantaneo e
passivo invece è in realtà il risultato
di un'elaborazione continua ma senza
soluzione di continuità
la scena visiva è costituita da una
rapida serie di immagini
che emergono dai cambiamenti di luce che
ci sono nella nostra etica
anche le persone piccole che vedete qui
o quelle che tra un attimo vedrete fuori
fuoco noi le percepiamo nei loro
particolari che non vediamo Perché
addirittura non ci sono
la sacca della signora le borse non
riusciamo a percepirle a immaginarle
come possono essere Dunque quello che
percepiamo come qualcosa in movimento in
realtà non lo è non lo è necessariamente
il cervello combina queste immagini e ci
restituisce la percezione del movimento
la luce colpisce i personaggi
e viene
introiettata dentro
un obiettivo
dovrebbe essere Robert Downey Jr
questa luce viene immagazzinata dentro
l'obiettivo e viene trasferita Su un
supporto sensibile che possiamo chiamare
la retina dello strumento di
registrazione
questa questa fotogramma che forse
qualcuno di voi ricorda perché siamo
nell'epoca del digitale è molto
sensibile addirittura nel
1941 Orson Wells produce un film fa la
regia di un film che si intitola Quarto
potere e senza Zan Kane e ad opera per
la prima volta nella storia della
cinematografia una pellicola particolare
si chiama pancromatica questa pellicola
ha delle caratteristiche particolari è
così sensibile che permette di chiudere
tantissimo il diaframma dell'obiettivo
in presenza di grandi illuminazione E
tutto quello che c'è sulla sulla
superficie della pellicola è messo a
fuoco Cioè ha delle capacità superiori a
quelle che sono la nostra retina nel
1941 Questo ha permesso a Orson Wells di
mettere a fuoco sia il bambino sullo
sfondo
che la madre che firma il contratto
Eppure il movimento delle cose
il film di Orson Wells
non potrebbe resistere senza la nostra
collaborazione
Siamo noi che con i nostri sensi
collaboriamo il manifestarsi di ogni
evento senza la mia vista Quarto potere
non esiste
il quadro di Van Gogh non esiste senza
il mio udito la magnifica sinfonia che
sto ascoltando non esiste perché
l'evento esige vuole prevede la mia
collaborazione la mia partecipazione ed
è sempre una parte una partecipazione
particolare che prevede una violenza che
ci viene fatta la violenza della luce
che scolpisce la mia retina come abbiamo
visto ma anche come la violenza del
suono che tamburella sui miei timpani
per farmi sentire la sinfonia quindi
l'atto di incisione è persistenza
questa persistenza È uno stratagemma
della natura che la natura usa per
permetterci di interpretare il mondo in
maniera causale e continuata
questa violenza pervade la nostra intera
esistenza tutta la nostra vita perché le
cose persistono che non lo si vogliono e
persistono in modo positivo
o in modo negativo
così come veniamo scolpiti dalla luce lo
siamo delle esperienze abbiamo scolpiti
non in modo passivo ma collaborativo
questa azione
che la realtà rovescia su di noi prevede
come vi dicevo la nostra partecipazione
anche
se tante volte la nostra partecipazione
è fare swipe sul telefono
questo Però
succede perché abbiamo l'illusione di
essere a noi controllare la cosa di
essere noi a selezionare i nostri
contenuti mettere in realtà siamo noi ad
essere selezionati e profilati per quei
contenuti
dunque se da un lato la persistenza
della visione può assumere il
significato
di un continuare a seguire uno scopo un
sogno e quindi un progetto di
miglioramento e quindi ha delle
caratteristiche positive
ed è dunque possibile
dare il nome di persistenza buona
dall'altro lato le esperienze e le
percezioni che noi abbiamo di questa
esperienza possono dare una persistenza
di una visione dichiaratamente negativa
molti giovani dopo diversi fallimenti
sono convinti che nella loro vita non la
cambierà e quindi abbandonano sforzi per
cercare di migliorare la loro situazione
la persistenza di una tale visione
scolpisce l'animo nell'intimo a queste
persone velocemente smarriscono ogni
impegno e speranza questa visione come
ogni altra tende ad autoalimentarsi
ovvero si fortifica nel tempo
e prende sempre maggior forza dunque se
da un lato la persistenza della visione
può assumere questo significato
dall'altro è negativo a queste persone
queste persone che vivono nel loro
dramma prese dalla persistenza della
loro visione manca una parola di
incoraggiamento
una pacca sulla spalla il conforto di un
apprezzamento oppure solo qualcuno che
le possa ascoltare che le voglia
ascoltare
che cambi la loro visione che persiste
in maniera così negativa è
incredibilmente potente La forza della
parola la parola può divenire luce
anche le persone stesse dunque lo
possono ognuno di noi può divenire una
luce positiva per qualcun altro
essere luce
per qualcun altro ma già lo siamo perché
così come possiamo scegliere di essere
una luce negativa possiamo scegliere di
divenire una luce positiva avendo cura
di chi ci sta attorno
auguro a tutti noi di diventare una luce
nuova che scolpisce grazie
[Applauso]